ricardo lange ist nicht nur deutschlands
bekanntester intensivpfleger sondern er
mischt inzwischen auch kräftig mit in
den politischen debatten herzlich
willkommen zu phoenix persönlicher lange
vielen dank dass ich dabei sein wird wir
freuen uns sehr lange in deutschland
heißt es es brennt die hütte und die
lage ist in der tat brenzlig es gibt
schwierigkeiten wohin man schaut was
beschäftigt sie denn im moment am
meisten also mich beschäftigt am meisten
dass wir irgendwie gefühlt seit drei
jahren von einer katastrophe in die
nächste schlendern der klimawandel krieg
corona pandemie und ich habe das gefühl
dass das dazu geführt hat dass die
meinungen in der gesellschaft sich
radikalisiert also nicht radikal im
sinne von gewalt und so sondern es ist
ja mittlerweile so entweder du bist
dafür oder dagegen also man darf gewisse
dinge einfach gar nicht mehr ansprechen
dann wenn ich jetzt nur mal als beispiel
war bei anne will und wenn du dann das
wort grundrecht in den mund nimmt dann
kriegst du sofort einen schützt da wird
dir sofort vorgehalten habe wie kannst
du über grundrechte reden beweist dass
es ja die rechten in die hände spielt
also egal welche meinung du irgendwie
vertrittst du musst immer eine radikale
gegenseite haben die dich bombardiert
mit mit hass nachrichten mit
beleidigungen mit du bist entweder bist
du der linksgrünen versuchte pfleger
weil du irgendwas zum klima gesagt hast
oder du bist der nazi pfleger weil du
grundrechte gesagt hast also dieser
mittelweg dieses miteinander weil wir
werden diese krise ja nur gemeinsam
überstehen und das fehlt mir so einfach
dass es einfach nur diese radikalen
meinungen gibt entweder dafür oder
dagegen haben sie das gefühl dass ich
das wirklich so massiv geändert hat war
das nicht auch schon immer so
also meine wahrnehmung ist verschieden
noch mal eine andere weil umso mehr man
natürlich in der öffentlichkeit steht
umso mehr gibt auch leute die sich dann
zu dem was man sagt auch äußern um so
mit mehr leuten kommt man auch im
kontakt mit dem man sich austauscht
aber ich finde schon dass ich das ganze
noch mal so ein bisschen zugespitzt hat
weil noch nie waren die menschen der in
seiner not wie heute also not corona
klar leben ist bedroht aber da waren ja
auch viele existenzen wie da dranhängen
ist waren kinder die nicht zur schule
gehen konnten das hat ja auch viele
schon aufgewühlten gestört jetzt haben
wir klimakrise wovon viele betroffen
sind viele wollen davon nichts hören für
viele sehr entscheidender teil zum
beispiel die überschwemmungen waren oder
jetzt der ukraine kriegt da sind ja auch
die meinung gespalten weil zum einen
sagt man wir brauchen die sanktionen um
russland in die knie zu zwingen und zum
anderen merken wir aber dass die
russland natürlich nicht nur den russen
schaden sondern auch uns und deswegen
ist das alles so ein bisschen die leute
sind natürlich aufgewühlt und es ist ja
seit drei jahren nur panik also panik im
sinne von irgendwelchen krisen die wir
zu bewältigen müssen wo man immer wieder
ängste ausstehen muss und das heißt
natürlich die gemüter auf und die leute
sind auch einfach dann und wann müde und
ich glaube dass deswegen auch noch mal
alles so ein bisschen dramatischer ist
lassen wir uns beim thema streit bleiben
und auch beim turnier thema not der
menschen die bundesregierung hat jetzt
ein entlastungs paket geschnürt in höhe
von 65 milliarden euro um die größte not
der bürgerinnen und bürger im winter zu
entlasten wie das paket schon heißt und
bezeichnet dieses paket als wuchtig
würden sie sagen dieses paketes wuchtig
genug es würden die worte ich genug sein
um alles abrufen zu können und ich
glaube von dem gedanken müssen so frei
machen dass wir mit den steuergeldern
der staat ist auf dauer alle nöte und
leiden der menschen abpuffern kann es
geht einfach dafür ist gar nicht genug
geld da
und wenn wir es ja entlastungspaket mal
an sich nehmen nehmen wir jetzt mal zum
beispiel mich ich würde mich jetzt zum
mittelstand zählen ich habe keine kinder
ich bin kein rentner bin kein
studierender bekomme kein wohngeld bin
also von vielen geldern ausgenommen und
so geht es ganz ganz vielen menschen
diesem land die täglich zur arbeit gehen
und immer so ein bisschen an rand so
vorbeischlittern so an irgendwelchen
grenzen wo man geld bekommen müsste
könnte wie auch immer und da sich ein
ganz großes problem alle die jetzt geld
bekommen haben es natürlich verdient und
brauchen es auch aber der mittelstand
leidet enorm darunter war der ist ja
derjenige der das geld auch rein spielt
und die ganzen ersparnisse die man hat
werden entweder von der inflation
aufgefressen oder werden für
krisensituationen wie jetzt einfach
drauf gehen bei viele wissen einfach gar
nicht mehr wie sollen sie ihre
gasrechnungen bezahlen wie sollen sie
die stromrechnung bezahlen selbst ich
bin und mir geht's gut ich habe keine
kinder kann man geld also für mich
ausgeben aber die kollegen jetzt auch
drei morgen mein t shirt kaufe ich mir
eine hose kaufen und so geht s ganz
vielen was wiederum natürlich die
wirtschaft blüht das ja auch irgendwie
abpuffern muss und ich habe einfach ein
ganz großes problem damit wenn dann so
politiker um stehen von homer abgucken
so fühlt sich das für mich an und sagen
ihr müsst euch mit dem waschlappen
waschen ihr müsst kurzer duschen sind
sehr wertvolle tipps klar sparen es
immer gut aber was machen die menschen
die schon seit vielen jahren sich mit
dem waschlappen waschen sie seit vielen
jahren nicht mehr richtig duschen kann
meine eltern zum beispiel nennen die
wohnung in hellersdorf
plattenbauwohnungen wenn ich dort zu
besuch komme früher im winter auch schon
vor der ukraine
situation weil einfach meine eltern gar
nicht das geld haben auf dauer diese
plattenbau diesen betonblock zu heizen
was machen den menschen die ich schon
immer sparen.de schon am limit sind wenn
dann zum beispiel herrn lindner von der
gratis mentalität spricht mit diesen
neuen euro ticket was wirklich vielen
menschen das erste mal seit jahren die
gelegenheit gegeben hat durch
deutschland zu reisen verwandte zu
besuchen mit ihren kindern mal andere
orte zu besuchen und dann natürlich für
ihn sind neun euro nicht viel von der
gratis mentalität zu sprechen und dann
nicht auf twitter darüber noch witzig
und lustig zu machen weil umgekehrt muss
man ja sagen neun euro sind für viele
familien schon viel geld aber wenn man
es mal umdreht so ein monatsticket
kostet jetzt momentan kenne die
aktuellen preise nicht 80 90 euro dann
spart man natürlich auch 80 euro und 80
euro sind für eine familie unter
umständen entscheiden kann ich mit den
wochenendeinkauf leisten oder nicht um
meine mutter würde würde mir heute noch
den mund mit seife auswaschen wenn ich
mich so herablassend über menschen
äußern würde die ja täglich versuchen
über die runden zu kommen werden wir
ruhig mal in berlin hellersdorf sie
sagen ja gerade ihre eltern leben noch
da sie selbst leben wir in einem kleinen
dorf in brandenburg
wenn wir jetzt die einzelnen punkte das
entlastungspaket weiter anschauen wir
waren schon 99 euro ticket des aufbaus
läuft es soll so um die 40 50 euro ein
weiteres geben näheres ist aber noch
erklärung wenn wir jetzt mal uns zum
beispiel das kindergeld anschauen da
geht es auch um viele viele
alleinerziehende die da dringend darauf
angewiesen sind aber sicherlich auch um
familien die weniger einkommen haben 18
euro pro kind mehr im jahr 2023 glauben
sie dass das in irgendeiner form
wirklich nützen kann
also jeder euro zählt ganz klar aber man
muss ja auch fairerweise sagen was sind
denn 18 euro für ein kind in einem monat
also meine schwester ich habe ja selber
zwei neffen und meine schwester allein
anziehen die muss auch jeden monat
gucken wie sie über die runden kommt und
ohne meine eltern also ohne dass meiner
mama zum beispiel von ihrem wenigen
etwas sie bekommt meine schwestern
unterstützt wurde sie auch den monat gar
nicht überleben und mit 18 euro kommst
du ja nicht weil die kinder müssen zur
schule
da müssen schulsachen gekauft werden da
müssen klamotten gekauft wenn die wurden
vielleicht mal ein eis essen also 18
euro für ein kind pro monat ist
natürlich jetzt nicht die welt und wird
die große not der menschen nicht lindern
und wie empfinden sie das wenn sie in
hellersdorfer straße spazieren gehen
oder wenn sie sich mit ihren freunden
und bekannten unterhalten da auch in
brandenburg haben die menschen das
gefühl dass die lebensrealität die sie
haben verstanden wird von politik haben
sie das gefühl dass ihnen da wirklich
geholfen wird oder geht es dann doch
mehr in richtung unmut und die da oben
und wieder und irgendwo das natürlich
sehr groß weil man muss fairerweise
sagen dass viele politiker die da oben
sind und über uns entscheiden die kennen
ja gar nicht unsere nöte die wissen
nicht wie es ist mit dem regelsatz von
hartz 4 klar zu kommen die wissen nicht
wie es ist mit 1500 2000 euro netto klar
zu kommen und man sieht ja ganz klar die
sprechen davon dass er ja ich sag mal
der wohlstand in deutschland vorüber ist
fliegen dann aber in einem im land also
innerhalb des landes mit einem privatjet
zu einer privaten hochzeit können jeden
jedes flugzeug aber ich frage mich immer
ob dieses symbol dieses zeichen das
richtige ist wenn man den leuten sagt er
leute tut uns leid dass ihr wohlstand zu
ende geht aber erstmal mit meinen
privatjet zu einer hochzeit von herrn
lindner ist keine kritik ist ein
flugzeug an sich aber ich finde die
politik sollte gewisse zeichen auch mal
selber setzen einfach um ein anderes
bild liefern wir finden einfach das
kommt von oben herab immer sehr komisch
rüber nun ist es ja so dass für den
herbst und winter unruhen befürchtet
werden also rechte und linke kräfte
haben auch bereits dazu aufgerufen und
es ging glaube ich letzte woche in
leipzig schon los
es vermittelt sich schon so dass oder
man hat schon häufiger das gefühl dass
die stimmung im osten schneller
aufgeheizt ist als im westen teilen sie
das
also also ich kenne jetzt nur von
hellersdorf sprechen da ist nun mal so
dass die menschen viel viel weniger geld
haben das dann natürlich
soziale brennpunkte sind und natürlich
wo ist den menschen schlechter geht sind
die natürlich auch eher bereit auf die
straße zu gehen und ich habe ein ganz
großes problem damit weil wir immer sagt
ja nur die linksradikalen und die
rechtsradikalen gehen die straße es gehe
noch menschen auf die straße die einfach
angst um ihre existenz haben und wenn
ich in meinem leben in meiner existenz
bedroht bin dein käfig zur not mit der
heugabel auf die straße weil was sollen
der mensch anders machen andere wahl hat
er mich und ich finde einfach diese
stigmatisierung im radikal linksradikal
rechts muss auch wenn natürlich werden
solche krisen auch von solchen
gruppierungen ich sag mal
instrumentalisiert ganz klar politik
funktioniert ja nur durch krisen wer die
welt in ordnung würde es keine probleme
geben dann welche wahlversprechen sollen
unsere politiker geben aber es gibt wie
gesagt auch menschen die einfach auf die
straße gehen weil sie nicht mehr wissen
wie sie morgen ihre rechnung bezahlt und
ich finde da muss man einfach anerkennen
und ich bin froh dass wir in einem land
wie deutschland leben in einer
demokratie und da ist auf die straße
gehen solange man sich an die gegebenen
gesetz also zum beispiel masken pflicht
wenn es dann eine gebe und so weiter an
gewisse regeln hält völlig legitim dass
man seine meinung auch auf der straße
kundtut das ist zum zweiten großen thema
com masken vielleicht haben sie gerade
schon gesagt es ist ein fließender
übergang
das ist uns noch mal über corona
sprechen sie haben gerade selbst eine
brunner infektion durchgemacht darf ich
sie fragen wie es eben geht oder wie wie
sie das erfahren haben also wenn die
krone kurz und knapp beschreiben müsste
wie der verlauf bei mir persönlich wäre
würde ich sagen war wieder stärker
angehen damit bandscheibenvorfall hatte
wirklich sehr sehr starke halsschmerzen
und rückenschmerzen war aber mit
ibuprofen und lutschtabletten nach fünf
tagen gut aus gestanden und so war es
bei mir zumindest haben sie denn das
gefühl dass wir jetzt im dritten jahr
der pandemie besser auf die herbst auf
die drohne vermeintlich drohende herbst
werde vorbereitet sind das ist auch mal
so ein bisschen warten auf die palme
bringt dass wir uns immer nur auf krone
fixieren also die frage ist immer sind
wir denn auf die nächste corona welle im
herbst gut vorbereitet die frage ist
also kann es ganz klar sagen nein weil
für mich sind maßnahmen die verhängt
werden keine vorbereitung auf irgendeine
krise damit kann man symptome bekämpfen
damit kann man vielleicht dinge einen
infektionen und so weiter aber der
wirkliche taktung ist doch der
personalmangel und dann muss man noch
die frage stellen wann hat man den satz
in den letzten drei jahren getan um oder
vorher schon um klinik personal
aufzustocken wir haben mittlerweile gar
nicht mal große sorge neues personal zu
kriegen sondern mittlerweile ist ja
schon das problem dass personal zu
halten was noch da ist und wir haben ja
nicht nur polemik kann es ganz offen
ehrlich sagen wir haben momentan eine
situation in den kliniken auf den
intensivstationen liegen 12
komapatienten und diese kommen mit
herzinfarkt oder autounfall zu uns
werden getestet und sind dann positiv so
wie es vor zwei jahren noch war in den
ersten zwei wellen wohl leute
ausschließlich wegen krone ins
krankenhaus kommen diese situation ist
momentan nicht aber wir haben ganz
andere sachen wir haben multiresistente
keime wo jedes jahr 20.000 menschen
sterben kann die eigene geschichte hat
sich ein kollege von mir hat sich im fuß
gebrochen musste das krankenhaus
normalerweise operationen ist an drei
tagen durch kannst du nach hause gehen
halt alles fertig er hat sich aber
multiresistenten keimen die wunde
eingefangen während der op das führte
dazu dass er acht wochen lang im
krankenhaus liegen musste unzählige
operationen erdulden musste literweise
antibiotika bekommen hat um diesen
keinem um gewechselt am ende war die
wunde so groß weil die ja immer wieder
weg geschnitten werden musste dass
dieses infizierte gewebe weg ist dass
man die haut nicht mehr verschließen
konnte und dann wird man den fuß noch
retten kann musste man aus dem
oberschenkelmuskel einen muskel strang
heraus operieren und ihnen nach unten
transplantieren klingt erstmal einfach
aber ist eine operation die mehrere
stunden dauert mit dem risiko dass
dieses transplantat nicht anwächst und
da frage ich mich warum wird dort
seitens der bundesregierung nicht
ausreichend gehandelt warum nimmt man
nicht geldern haben wie bei der korona
impfung und an dem jetzt so pharmafirmen
um nach neuen antibiotika zu forschen
weil die werden es freiwillig nicht
machen weil wenn jetzt zum beispiel sagt
man bayer schering neues antibiotikum
auf den markt bringen zählt das als
reserve antibiotikum das heißt es wird
nur in äußersten notfall eingesetzt also
ist die verkaufsmarke gering aber danach
kann es ja nicht gehen im mittelpunkt
hat immer die gesundheit der menschen zu
stehen so wie es ja auch immer gesagt
wird und es lässt sich nicht nur auf
corona beziehen sondern mit muss ja
breitgefächert stattfinden wenn wir aber
trotzdem bei corinna nochmal bleiben es
werden hier werden ja oder es gibt neue
krone regeln für den herbst die
aufregung ist bei vielen groß weil man
unter anderem im flugzeug eine maske
tragen soll oder kann man jetzt hat
maske mehr tragen muss in bussen und
bahnen aber offenbar doch können sie das
nachvollziehen ich verstehe also ist ja
wie in der ganzen corona pandemie ein
wirrwarr immer man hat ja manchmal
zurzeit in manchen phasen der pamir
googeln müssen welche maßnahmen jetzt
überhaupt aktuell sind in welchem
bundesland war ja auch immer
unterschiedlich der ist doch genauso wie
letztes jahr zu weihnachten da wurde
gesagt es wird kontakt beschränkungen
geben aber erst nach den feiertagen habe
ich damals schon gesagt entschuldigung
herr lauterbach werden heute mein haus
brennt der jet entweder heute und ich
das in drei tagen ist die bude
abgefackelt und dem verstehe halt so
noch nicht genau wie die menschen
entweder wir haben den massencrash in
allen verkehrsmitteln auch im flugzeug
oder eben keine aber wir verstehen diese
unterscheidung kann ich leider nicht
nachvollziehen aufregung gab es auch
weil die länder also die bundesländer im
herbst wenn die zahlen drastisch steigen
würden prokura hätten um auch wieder
eine masken pflicht ab dem ab der
fünften klasse in den schulen anzuordnen
wir erleben sie da die situation der
kinder oder wie schauen sie auf auf auf
diese maßnahmen in den letzten jahren
und auch mit der möglichkeit dass es
jetzt doch eventuell wieder kommen
können sondern also ich weiß ich bin
eher als leiharbeiter für alle die mich
nicht kennen unterwegs und besucher
viele kliniken hier in berlin oder ich
weiß von vielen kliniken die auch eine
kinderpsychiatrie haben dass dort die
fälle
verhaltensauffälligen kindern gestiegen
ist und auch in den evolutionsbedingt
der das war scharf kritisiert wird aber
auch dort ist es ja beschrieben dass
eine erhöhte auffälligkeit psychische
auffälligkeit also depression und so
weiter bei kindern herrscht und ich
finde einfach man muss genau gucken ist
denn die massen pflicht für kinder jetzt
sinnvoll oder nicht es gibt viele die
fordern sind viele sind dagegen ich
finde da muss viel mehr geforscht ob sie
es auch notwendig ist und da bin ich
gesichter experte der welt beurteilen
kann aber ich finde gerade die kinder
haben genug in der pandemie gelitten und
natürlich muss man die gesundheit der
kinder und erwachsenen schützen aber das
zählt eben wie gesagt nicht nur auf
krone sondern muss eben immer gucken
welche vorteile bietet mir die maßnahme
und welche nachteile hat man und da muss
man abwägen welcher weg der richtige ist
pflege am limit ist das schon auch
öffentlich seit zwei jahren ihr thema es
fing alles an mit einer
bundespressekonferenz mit dem ehemaligen
gesundheitsminister jens spahn und wir
wollen das noch mal reinschauen
in eine situation in der sie die
einsamkeit der sterbenden sowie
patienten auf ihrer station schildern
aufgrund des infektionsschutzgesetzes
ist es jetzt so dass die familie erst
kommen darf wenn sich abzeichnet dass
der patient in kürze versterben wird und
jetzt stellen sie sich vor sie kommen
ins krankenhaus und müssen abschied
nehmen mit mundschutz mit kittel mit
handschuhen sie haben keinen
körperlichen kontakt und auch wenn die
mama noch ansprechbar sein sollte was in
den meisten fällen leider nicht mehr ist
sieht sie sie zum letzten mal mit maske
vermittelt und das ist das letzte was
sie sieht und dazu kommt dass wir
pflegekräfte wenn die patienten dann
leider verstorben sind eben diese
menschen wieder zum infektionsschutz ins
schwarze plastiksäcke packen müssen
wir legen sie dort hinein und ziehen den
reißverschluss und glauben sie mir wenn
ich ihnen sage das macht was mit einem
welche reaktionen haben sie damals
verkommen so viel hass macht richtig
viel hass nachrichten weil für das aber
sie meine es wird das für oder gegen
etwas weil es gab ja auch andere acht
minuten wo ich quasi auch herrn sparen
kritisiert habe und gesagt habe dass
corinna nur die typischen ist aber da
habe ich ihm ganz viele nachrichten
bekommen
das hat alles bullshit ist und habe auch
in der pressekonferenz von der mutter
erzählt die da gestorben ist da wurde
mir erzählt dass menschen starben liegt
weil ich dann eigentlich will das macht
er keine arbeit mehr wieder stirbt ja
schon warum ich dann heule und auch mit
dieser aussage mit dem plastiksäcken
packen wurde mir erklärt dass also der
vergleich wurde gestellten möhlmann der
sehr möglich in säcke packen kann hat in
den falschen job wurde mir also gesagt
wenn ich damit nicht klarkommen habe ich
den falschen beruf und ich fand einfach
so krass dass man menschen und
pflegekräfte als müll und müllmänner
gleichsetzt und da hat man schon gemerkt
krass also das hat schon echt an denen
man seinen glauben der menschen bei mir
schon sehr gerüttelt muss man sein sie
sind ja auch sehr aktiv bei twitter auch
bei instagram und erzählen da viel aus
ihrem alltag aber ihr äußern durch autos
eben auch ihre meinung zur anderen
politischen prozessen und vorgängen
wenn sie sagen es geht immer sehr
polarisiert so kann man übrigens da auch
sehen dass es auch den anderen themen
durchaus sehr polarisiert zugeht wie
gehen sie damit um gestecken sie das weg
dass man an gefangenen gut ja also ich
sage mir einfach immer und jeder der
eine weile darauf den sozialen
netzwerken folgte kann es ja auch
beobachten ich muss damit leben wenn ich
mich öffentlich zu gewissen dingen
äußere und auch kritisch äußere dass es
immer menschen geben wird die mich nicht
leiden können die mit meiner aussage
nicht übereinstimmen und mich einfach
blöd würden und dieses recht hat jeder
mensch und dieses recht gestellte
menschen zu ob man deswegen jetzt
jemanden beleidigen muss ob man deswegen
jetzt ungefragt
böse nachrichten schicken muss steht auf
einem anderen blatt papier aber ich habe
mir einfach gesagt ricardo nur weil
jemand unfair gegenüber es nur wer dich
jemand beleidigt musst du es nicht mit
ihnen machen und jeder wenn ich dann
dazu komme zu antworten kriegt von mir
eine nette respektvolle nachricht zurück
und so gehe ich damit um und wenn es mir
reicht sowie nach anne will zum beispiel
wo viele einfach drüber waren da werden
diese menschen blockiert das waren genau
vier profile dich da blockiert habe und
dann antworte ich darf auch einfach
nicht ich würde sogar noch auf einen
tweet ansprechen über den ich
zugegebenermaßen sehr gestolpert bin in
den letzten
tagen in dem sie schildern wie die
tochter eines sterbenden patienten sie
gebeten hat aufzupassen dass ihr papa
gut
rüberkommt und dass ihr das versprochen
haben und einige tage später haben sie
bei instagram ausführlicher aber kürzer
auch bei twitter geschrieben was sie
nicht weiß ihr vater wird in dieser
nacht einsam in seinem zimmer sterben
und sie sagen dass das eine notlüge war
warum twittern sie so private sachen da
frage ich mich wirklich ganz persönlich
auch recht fertig da der zweck solche
mittel also erstmal zwitter ich nie
aktuelle situation die situation ein
bisschen älter und diese situation die
man dort schildert so einfach die
gesamtsituation in unserem beruf
darstellen und die leute müssen es so
direkt wissen es diesen vorfall der
schon ewig her und es war auch man also
man schreibt dass sich niemand
wiederfindet aber wir gehen seit monaten
seit jahren auf die straße um vermehrt
neuerdings wir rufen um hilfe wir sagen
dass es nicht weitergeht dass menschen
sterben weil nicht genug personal das
wir werden nicht gehört und ich finde
einfach so langsam muss auch die
gesellschaft wach gerüttelt werden und
sagen okay wenn sich nichts ändert ist
das aber da ist zustand und es ist
momentan so dass sehr häufig eben keine
zeit ist menschen beim sterben zu
begleiten und jeder muss sich die frage
stellen wenn ich in der endphase meines
lebens bin habe keine angehörigen mehr
oder die können mentalen ich bei mir
bleiben will ich alleine sterben zimmer
weil ich da alleine die letzten minuten
meines lebens bringen oder will ich
lieber dass jemand bei mir ist der mir
die schmerzen nimmt der mir die hand
hält der einfach mich gut rüberbringt
und diese frage muss man sich stellen
diese verantwortung hat auch die
gesellschaft und natürlich gab es viel
kritik wie kann man denn lügen aber soll
man sich vor der tochter hinstellen die
somit ein riesen sagen tut mir leid wir
haben leider keine zeit er vater wird
alleine sterben würde man es so machen
hätten zu bleiben vielleicht viele
können es nicht man muss akzeptieren
dass viele diesen weg eben nicht gehen
können ich selber habe meine cousine
verloren die es an einem erhöhen arisman
gestorben mein onkel der ein jahr später
krebs gestorben ist steht auch im buch
der konnte auch nicht bei ihr bleiben
und das ist einfach zu akzeptieren es
schafft hält nicht jeder mental seinem
allerliebsten menschen den er so gern
auf der welt hat beim sterben zuzusehen
dafür sind eigentlich wir da um dann
diese sterbebegleitung zu machen und man
muss offen sagen können das ist momentan
nicht möglich ist
sie sprechen ja viele berufsgruppen über
die pfleger zur wahrheit scheint aber
nun zu ihrer wahrheit jedenfalls scheint
auch dazu zu gehören dass ihr sie mit
ihrer eigenen berufsgruppe durchaus auch
manchmal nicht einverstanden sind ich
lese das mal vor damit ich es nicht
falsch sagen sie haben in einem
interview gesagt wir sind eher eine
berufsgruppe die sehr viel jammert oft
zu recht aber wir zeigen auch gerne mit
dem finger auf andere ohne uns selbst zu
bewegen wo bleibt der ihre solidarität
also es ist da so die recht also mann
sammer zurecht aber wir zeigen auf die
gesellschaft ihr müsst wir zeigen ob die
medien da die medienberichten nicht
genug aber was haben denn die medien
zwei jahre lang gemacht die medien haben
zwei jahre lang jeden tag den
pflegenotstand thematisiert sie haben
thema der es gab genug zeitungsberichte
videos wo pflegepersonal heulen auf dem
flug gesetzt hat also wir alle
aufmerksamkeit der welt was haben wir
draus gemacht nichts nichts gemacht wir
haben uns nicht engagiert und ich kann
es ja selber sagen man man man bemüht
sich man trifft vielleicht nicht immer
den richtigen ton mann macht kaum einen
beitrag der fläche hätte anders machen
können aber es gibt immer die eigene
berufsgruppe die denn da sitzt und sagt
dass er das so machen müssen warum hast
du denn toni gemacht aber selber machen
sich gar nix nix und das ist meine
kritik und es im berufsalltag genauso
sie sind frühdienst übergeben den
spätesten dienst und der spätdienst
guckt was hat derjenige falsch gemacht
hat er vergessen und anstatt die kritik
dann vielleicht selber zu äußern wurde
dann ein zettel geschrieben wird über
dritte überreicht als wir machen uns ja
selber fertig anstatt alle mal
zusammenraufen und sagen so leute jetzt
ist hier schicht dann fragt jetzt gehen
wir mal gemeinsam zum beispiel die
straße nicht immer verein zählt und da
der nächste kritikpunkt dann gibt es
pflege hatte die gehen auf die strasse
werden von ihren eigenen kollegen die
eben nicht auf die straße gehen als
unsolidarisch bezeichnet wie könnt ihr
nur wir müssen eure arbeit alleine
machen aber die reifen sicher trotzdem
die hände wenn dann dinge erstreckt
werden die zu einer besserung fühlen
führen und ich finde einfach
wir müssen von dem gedanken wegkommen
dass unten hält auf dem weißen beratungs
rät angeritten kommt und für uns den
karren aus dem dreck sieht und ich kann
noch nicht mal sagen die gesellschaft
muss die politik ja die politik muss
auch und die medien sind alle schuld
jede pflegekraft wie jeden tag immer
wieder einspringen und dabei hilft dem
personalmangel zu verschleiern jede
pflegekraft die sich selber ab nutzt
sich ab nutzen lässt ausbrennt ist ja
auch keine hilfe für den patienten denn
eine pflegekraft die immer wieder
anspringt die sich nicht mehr erholt die
nicht mehr konzentriert und empathisch
ist ist ja eigentlich nicht mehr in der
lage die arbeit so auszuführen wie es
sein sollte und da muss jede pflegekraft
verantwortung übernehmen und nicht jede
pflegekraft hat die kraft auf die straße
zu gehen nicht jede pflegekraft hat die
kraft sich politisch zu engagieren aber
jede pflegekraft kann noch sagen pass
auf ich habe heute urlaub komme aus
meinem urlaub nicht zurück denn ich muss
für mich für meine familie da sein und
das heißt auch verantwortung für sich
selbst und für den patienten zu
übernehmen weil wenn wir das system am
laufen halten wo wir alle nicht mehr
arbeiten wollen dann müssen wir uns aber
nicht weiter beschweren sie haben gerade
gesagt politik muss auch lassen wir doch
mal zurückschauen diese pressekonferenz
damals auch sehr wie den ausschnitt
gesehen haben war ja auch der
startschuss für viele treffen mit
verschiedensten politikern
unterschiedlicher die sie hatten was
würden sie sagen haben sie da erreichen
kann
da habe ich erreichen können ich hatte
die gelegenheit mit vielen großen
politikern zu sprechen und habe selbst
auch viel über politik lernen können zum
beispiel dass so eine krisensituation
sei es der krieg sei es die korona
pandemie natürlich ist man super
eine super möglichkeit ist für die
politik zu sagen was sie alles machen
wollen was in zukunft also geplant ist
man redet dann mit dem volk mit mir zb
als krankenpflegerin sammelt natürlich
für viele sympathiepunkte ich musste
aber auch lernen dass die anfängliche
euphorie natürlich ist man orcas mann
kam mit olaf scholz sprechen man kann
mit jens spahn oder jetzt mit herrn
lauterbach sprechen ist man natürlich
erstmal kuhlmann wird gehört die leute
interessieren sich dafür wenn man dann
aber feststellen muss dass sie
versprechen die eingegeben wurden nicht
gehalten werden dann weiß man was dieses
gespräch letztendlich wert war und auch
hier olaf scholz hat mir von mann zu
mann die faust darauf gegeben dass er
sich für uns einsetzen wird ich hatte
das auch öffentlich noch mal bei twitter
kritisiert bis heute keine antwort herr
lauterbach hat nach dem schützen bei
anne will sich mit mir solidarisiert hat
bei twitter geschrieben dass er sich auf
eine gemeinsame zusammenarbeit freut ich
habe in rücksprache mit seinem
pressesprecher hanno kautz eine e mail
verfasst an die von ihm vorgegebene e
mail geschickt und auch bis heute keine
antwort also sehr gerne nachholen wird
wer weiß vielleicht klappt das ja nach
dieser sendung genau ihr könnt ja nicht
ausschließen das heißt insgesamt gesehen
was würden sie sagen wie glaubwürdig ist
in politik sie nach diesen ganzen
begegnungen und nach dem rückblick auf
die letzten jahre politik wird für mich
dann zu 100 prozent glaubwürdig wenn sie
die probleme angeht wenn immer nur davon
gesprochen wird man mit diesem mann will
das aber gucken wir nur mal auf mein
thema weil er kenne mich am besten aus
mit dem pflege thema was wurde denn wie
gesagt in den letzten drei jahren getan
um die situation in unserer berufsgruppe
signifikant zu verändern und nicht nur
für uns sondern auch für die patienten
denn man ist da immer wieder betont es
geht um menschenleben es geht um das
wohl der patienten um die sicherheit der
patienten was hat man getan um das
signifikant zu verändern die
bürgerversicherung stand bei der spd im
wahlprogramm stand bei den grünen im
wahlprogramm war aber das erste was in
den koalitionsverhandlungen rausgeflogen
ist mir wurde begründet die fdp schuld
aber so einfach kannst du dann auf mich
sein na ja gut aber bei einem
dreierbündnis ist es natürlich schon so
dass ich nicht immer nur einer
durchsetzt sondern dass man dem anderen
auch in zugestellt besser machen dann
unbedingt die bürgerversicherung warum
fliegt dann gerade das haus ich finde
diese zwei klassen medizin die wir haben
einfach furchtbar sich vorstellen sie
kriegen haben eine krebserkrankung
liegen im krankenhaus
und neben ihnen liegt auch ein patient
hat die gleiche erkrankung wie sie
gleiche alter gleichen probleme sie sind
privat versichert und die patienten
kassen versichert jetzt haben sie die
chemo haben keinen appetit habe schon
probleme zum essen und dann kriegen sie
ja so eine abhörwanze krankenhaus stelle
als kassenpatient was eh schon
unappetitlich aussieht und sie als
privatpatienten kriegen dann salat den
besten joghurt cornflakes keine ahnung
steak was auch immer sie haben wollen
das hat auch was mit gesund werden zu
tun und ich finde einfach es kann nicht
sein dass der soziale status darüber
entscheidet wie meine medizinische
betreuung und meine medizinische
behandlung ist oder versuchen sie doch
mal als kassenpatienten facharzt
hinzukriegen geht nicht da müssen sie
monate warten wenn es aber so am telefon
sagen sie sind kein privatpatient dann
können sie heute noch vorbeikommen und
das finde ich ein unding und mein
facharzt wo ich hingehe hat sogar noch
getrennte warteräume da gibt es im
warteraum für privatpatienten ganz oben
drüber geschrieben sie sitzen in orange
mit ledersesseln und der kassenpatienten
sitzt auf einem holzhocker mich stürzen
holzhocker aber wenn wir in deutschland
immer von diskriminierung reden warum
fangen wenn nicht auch mal daran ja
alles gleich zu machen da frage ich
nicht aber ehrlich gesagt herr lange
warum sie so ein arzt überhaupt dann auf
suchen sein mit seinen also ich meine
das ist ja schon in der tat sie sind ja
ein wehrhafter mensch und protestieren
sie da nicht bei ihrem arzt besprechen
sind es dann nicht da auch doch noch
klar ich habe einen blödsinn um meine
frau und ich komme ich bin kassenpatient
über jetzt ein termin haben also ich bin
und bin und so frech wenn ich meinen
terminen nicht kriege entweder wird
plätzen beim hautarzt selber bezahlt war
nicht anders mit 30 euro zahlen müssen
aber zur not ein
privatpatient gehen sabin kassenpatient
also wenn die leute das auch wird man
meckert immer über die überlassung zb
der rettung stellen viele menschen gehen
in die rettungsstelle mit bauchschmerzen
mit rückenschmerzen weil sie sonst
monatelang warten müssten offenen
facharzttermin auf eine magenspiegelung
auf dem mrt termin und die leute kürzen
einfach ab indem sie in die
rettungsstelle gehen wenn man dir
stellen also in lassen will muss man
doch auch da anfangen also ich finde
einfach dass jeder egal welches
einkommen hat das recht hat auf eine
angemessene und zeitnahe medizinische
behandlung haben sie auch nicht überlegt
zu mal selber in die politik zu gehen
die linken haben sie ja als wahlmann
nominiert für die bundespräsidentenwahl
wäre das was für sie weil ich einfach
wahrscheinlich zu ehrlich könnte
niemanden an schwinden könnte nie
irgendwie zu ehrlich zur politik genauer
also es gibt mit sicherheit auch
ehrliche politiker ich glaube aber nicht
dass die auf dauer weit kommen werden
herr lange vielen dank für das gespräch
[Musik]